During our first big-screen introduction to
Isla Nublar, many of us fell in love with
the Jurassic Park movies, but in the 20-plus
years since then, fans have uncovered many
mistakes and issues with the films.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm explaining how Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom fixes or addresses six movie
mistakes and complaints fans have about the
Jurassic movies.
Spoilers ahead for the Jurassic World movies,
so take care if you haven't seen them yet.
The brutal, drawn-out death of Claire's personal
assistant Zara in Jurassic World attracted
plenty of criticism.
Zara's demise, which saw her being pounced
on by multiple Pteranodons and snapped up
by a Mosasaur, certainly seemed over the top
given all she'd done was lose track of Claire's
nephews after they were dumped on her.
For Fallen Kingdom though, co-writer Colin
Trevorrow says he learned his lesson, and
told Empire that he "made sure that every
death was earned.
Everybody deserves their death in this movie."
He explained that it's "horrible people" who
massistant Eli Mills.
The T-Rex goat scene in Jurassic Park is an
iconic moment and there was a brief call-back
to it in the first Jurassic World.
Yet some niggling questions have been raised
about the original scene, such as given the
size of the goat, why would a T-Rex leave
a leg behind and not eat the whole animal.
Well, in Fallen Kingdom when the T-Rex is
moved into Lockwood Manor's basement and she
eats the goat, this time the filmmakers specifically
showed Rexy swallowing up that final goat
leg.
And there's another little nod to that Jurassic
Park goat moment when Rexy is chomping down
on Eli Mills and one of his legs flies off,
Carnotaurus catches it but then leaves it
behind after being scared off by Rexy.
By the way, the T-Rex and goat scene was actually
censored in some countries like Italy and
I talk more about that in my video on Fallen
Kingdom's deleted and censored scenes.
Something that irked many fans in Jurassic
World was how Claire managed to spend the
whole movie running around the island in stilettos.
Of course, watching a dinosaur movie means
we have to suspend our disbelief, but seeing
a T-Rex outrun by Claire who was wearing high
heels that never snapped, just seemed a little
too silly and unnecessary.
Bryce Dallas Howard defended her stilettos
saying they reflected how her character was
more at home in a corporate environment and
was disconnected from the animals in the park.
Fallen Kingdom director J.A.
Bayona acknowledged Jurassic World's "heel-gate"
with his first shot of Claire in Jurassic
World 2 focusing on her in heels in the office
elevator, just like the first movie.
However, once Claire gets back on the island,
she ditches her heels for some sturdy boots,
a much more practical choice for the sequel's
action scenes.
Although it's well known that many real-life
dinosaurs had feathers, none in the first
Jurassic Park movie did.
In fact, dinosaur consultants on that movie
did recommend that dinos such as the raptors
and the T-Rex should have feathers; however,
unfortunately, computer animation at that
time couldn't handle creating feathers realistically
so the idea was abandoned.
The movie's scientific inaccuracy was acknowledged
by Jurassic Park 3's filmmakers who gave a
nod to feathered dinosaurs by adding a little
tuft of quills to the velociraptors.
But when the franchise returned with Jurassic
World, a decision was made to stick with featherless
raptors.
Director Colin Trevorrow defended this choice
by saying that Steven Spielberg had been unhappy
with the look and feel of feathered dinosaurs
in the Terra Nova TV series which Spielberg
executive produced between the original and
new trilogy.
Jurassic World 2 addresses its lack of feathered
raptors by adding a little tuft of quills
to the new Indoraptor's head while still maintaining
the franchise's continuity by keeping the
overall scaly look of most of the Jurassic
dinos.
By the way, the movies have an in-universe
justification for the lack of accuracy in
their dino designs as they aren't pure dinosaurs
as their genes have been mixed with, for example,
frog DNA.
And Wu explained in Jurassic World that Masrani
wasn't interested in realistic-looking dinos,
just scarier ones.
"If their genetic code was pure, many of them
would look quite different."
"But you didn't ask for reality."
"You asked for more teeth."
Although Jurassic Park 3 is one of the less
popular entries in the franchise, many fans
do love the Spinosaurus which was introduced
in that movie.
And key to designing that dinosaur was Ricardo
Delgado, who contributed storyboards and concept
art for the creature.
Delgado is a film and comic book artist who
went uncredited for his contributions to the
movie; however, Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
pays homage to him with an easter egg via
congresswoman Delgado who Claire speaks to
on the phone to get support for her plan to
the save the dinosaurs from their impending
extinction on Isla Nublar.
One big complaint that fans had about Jurassic
World was that there were too many CG dinosaurs
and not enough of the old-school animatronic
dinos they loved from the original movie.
We did get an animatronic Apatosaurus scene
in Jurassic World, but Colin Trevorrow explained
that budget limitations meant they were only
able to write one scene for an animatronic
dino.
Bu after the financial success of that movie,
the sequel had a much larger budget and it
hired Star Wars practical effects legend Neal
Scanlan to create new animatronic dinos for
the film.
Trevorrow, who co-wrote the script, made sure
to include close-up scenes with Blue, T-Rex
and the Indoraptor.
The scene with the injured Blue where Owen,
Zia, Franklin and Claire all interact with
the raptor is very realistic and the use of
animatronics gave an opportunity for the actors
to have a real physical and emotional connection
to the dino.
More than ten people were under the table
operating Blue during that scene and the creature
was even able to sweat and drool.
The Indoraptor's close-up scenes also used
puppeteers to get more realistic and scarier
shots.
VFX was then also added on top to enhance
certain moments difficult to replicate with
puppetry, such as the blink of an eye or a
snarl.
Now, let me know what plot holes or movie
mistakes you spotted in Fallen Kingdom?
And what did you most enjoy about the movie?
By the way, I've got a new giveaway for The
First Purge out now: you can win this cool
4K TV, Blu-ray player and Purge trilogy boxset.
Click the Gleam link in the video description
to enter!
If you liked this video, a thumbs-up is really
appreciated.
Tap left for the top 10 Fallen Kingdom deleted
scenes or tap right for my ending explained
and Jurassic World 3 video.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!